democrats are pushing a socialist
spending spree that would make karl marx
blush i've only seen him in black and
white photos so that would certainly be
interesting senate democrats ramming
through what could be the largest
expansion of big government in decades
it's not an exaggeration try to follow
this with a 3.5 trillion dollar filled
liberal filled bill of wish list items
including everything from amnesty to
clean energy free pre-k free community
college paid leave and elder care
republicans wasting no time tearing into
it
the policies they want to put behind
this budget resolution read like
somebody walked across the rotunda to
the house
and handed the squad
a pen
and piece of paper
senate democrats have made it clear
that they want to use this reckless tax
and spending spree to implement the
green new deal
you're spending money like drunken
sailors they're just throwing every
liberal idea and hope it sticks to the
wall they're going to change your
country
it's going to be more like venezuela and
less latin america don't worry about
they're going to pay for they're going
to up the corporate rate from 28 to 21.
did they just negotiate the fact that
donald trump's tax reform plan was
untouchable in the 1.2 trillion deal and
then they're going to take capital gains
and take it from 23 percent to 43.4
percent uh so okay we're changing
everything austin does that please you
brian
as a a switch to decaf but b
maybe in honor of the compromise of
yesterday we should agree that rather
than have a liberal
spending spree wish list let's only do
those things that are supported by the
large majority of the american people
oh yeah
that's exactly what they did
polls show that 69
of the country supports the build back
better agenda including 50
of self-proclaimed republicans and if
you look at this bill it's not a
socialist
mantra whatever you said it is it's a
list of investing in health care
investing in education investing in the
factory jobs and technology
paid for by raising taxes on high income
corporations and all i will point out is
joe biden ran for president saying this
is exactly what i will spend money on
and here is how i will pay for it he won
by seven million votes he got the house
he got the senate and now he's doing
what he said he would do uh austin i
think he's doing what bernie sanders
said he would do which means bernie
sanders didn't get the nomination degan
is this still america is this still a
democracy is this still capitalism
the three and a half let's call it five
trillion dollar five trillion dollar
plus plan that we're that we're now
talking about creates vast new
entitlements that will last
well beyond uh 10-year period that means
it gets the middle class hooked on
government handouts it's not investing
it's spending um and handing over
decision-making to the likes of bernie
and chuck schumer and nancy pelosi but i
find it rich that say lindsey graham
even a mitch mcconnell are now bitching
about spending they signed on to this
this infrastructure 1.1 yeah but had
already spent including what was passed
this year we had already spent six
trillion dollars so anyway so you get a
you get a bipartisan infrastructure plan
it was like more than two-thirds of the
senate that never happens so where's the
media in calling out nancy pelosi and
her nincompoops for not pushing it
through now she's tied it to the three
and a half to five trillion dollar plan
she won't put a vote on it this is a
huge win for joe biden and she's you
know this is heinous heel diggery on her
part she's owned by the left she's owned
by aoc she's owned by bernie's bernie
sanders chuck schumer is worried about
aoc primary in them uh dana nincompoops
we can't approve of this language uh but
uh dana in particular joe manchin said
i'm not happy with the 3.5 i'll let this
move forward but i'm not going to go for
all that money does that make you feel
better no
because do you think that i mean every
time everybody thinks that joe manchin
is the savior but look at his historical
uh voting record that's not just he
might not be for 3.5 but he could be for
3.3 right i mean but i also think that
some of these things like to your point
about the polls it's a good one however
think back to the 2020 election and
ask anybody medicare for all you like it
yeah i love it i love it but do you like
it if this happens and that's when all
the polling starts to fall apart so
republicans do have a lot of work to do
to try to explain their position on this
uh
they better hurry but there's another
piece which is on the immigration front
now this could might get thrown out
because it doesn't have anything to do
with uh the budget and reconciliation
will be the hero however this is what
they want to do um the immigration
language is very vague so what they've
said is that basically
lawful permanent status for qualified
immigrants this is not just your
dreamers dreamers would be about 700 000
this would get you up to about 10
million so now you have several senators
who are in very tough races like mark
kelly
and then
i would put gene shaheen of new
hampshire in that category and because
of all of these policies and in
particular this one the republicans are
actually looking at senator michael
bennett as a turnover opportunity in
colorado that would be amazing uh for
republicans and not only that so if you
say nine million are now legal uh greg
we're going to get another 10 million
raging at our border and we don't have
we have an administration that doesn't
really care about our border yeah i want
to talk about
china okay on this show yes on this
because you do have your own company
so you got the infrastructure bill and
it's got these carve outs for companies
to use foreign labor and material if
it's too expensive in america and that
means one word china right and so people
keep saying oh we're in this new cold
war with china but i grew up in the cold
war and nike
and apple and the nba they weren't
blowing tongue kisses to the to moscow
while we were awaiting our annihilation
while we were hiding under desks and
doing nuclear you know nuclear bomb
testing uh our corporations weren't
playing games with them so it's starting
to look like china is responsible for
all our kids
i don't have any masking up our
relatives dying and our friend's
business is being ruined you could point
to china for that
but we don't want that to interfere with
our cheap products and our in our
profits so the reality is until we
accept paying higher prices for labor
material we're going to be in bed with
the nation responsible for the worst
biological disaster in history and i
think there were 16 or 17 republicans
who signed on to that infrastructure
bill knowing that right uh that's good
does that answer your immigration
question mr kill me no but it makes you
feel better and i know emotion you're
emotional i feel better i'm less abusive
towards you in a way i think you're 100
correct
although when i feel good i i want to
hurt you more and i think i speak for i
thank you for dane i'm surprised the way
you're getting along with austin i still
i thought compared to you yeah
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else